you want me to sue the son of a
County Sheriff because he arrested my
kid on a false warrant a Utah County
Commissioner is accused of using his
authority to intimidate law enforcement
when his son is arrested for an
outstanding warrant what do you want me
to do I want you to turn him loose I
can't turn him loose Bruce who can
nobody can he's been arrested for a
warrant the corks can and the warrants
false huh the word's not false the
incident stems from a November 25th
traffic stop when Kenneth Adams was
pulled over for failure to signal and
stop fully at a stop sign
what did I do wrong okay so the reason I
stopped is you didn't come to complete
stop the stop sign I did and then you
didn't have your turn signal on I sure
did body camera video shows San Juan
County sheriff's deputies speaking with
Adams who maintains he did not violate
any rules okay I know for a fact I had
my turn signal okay that's why the
surprise you're throwing me over but
whatever when officials run Adams's ID
they find a warrant out for his arrest
come walk back up there
I'm just about
is we play some West for more I guess
after one as officials reapproach the
vehicle Adams becomes argumentative
I can get you to step out the vehicle
with me what are you doing no what
what's going on seriously what's going
on you have a warrant do I have a
warrant Adams tells officers the warrant
is a mistake saying he already appeared
in court I don't know how you having a
warrant but it's on our system right now
you have an active warrant out of seven
district court here in San Juan I've
gone to no that's incorrect so it's on
our system right now well I'm not gonna
argue with you about it you're gonna go
to jail tonight on that warrant okay no
I'm not I'm sure I don't
excuse me like no okay this is dude this
is Mr Adams you do have an active
warrant for your arrest and you and who
who is the warrant though the courts of
course for what though because I've gone
to court for everything there should not
be an active warrant for me anywhere
dude eventually Adams agrees to get out
of the vehicle after that he calls his
mom what's that I'm calling my parents
okay you can call them I'm gonna put you
in touch real quick
[Applause]
he's playing
when they're arresting me right now
the cops are mom who else would arrest
me Adams repeatedly tells his mom the
call is not a joke I'm going to jail
mom they are handcuffing me right now I
I've asked them for the warrant they
won't they don't tell me anything about
search for it
so
nothing not using anything Mom they're
arresting me because they said there was
a warrant for me okay I'm hanging the
phone up no I'm not kidding mom Sarah's
deputies escort Adams to the back of a
squad car where he continues to ask
about the warrant well then my question
is who
a joke this is seriously the biggest
joke I've ever heard of
[Music]
when you when you turned on your lights
I knew there was somebody
issued October 13th for last year
for what
I had some felony charges burglary
charges dude I've been to court for that
no no I've been to court for that all
right listen look that way real quick
um well if I've been to court then that
then why am I getting arrested I don't
know I don't know what all the courts
purchases are for filing the war all I
know is there is a warrant okay
so that's gonna be up to you and of
course to be able to figure that out all
right officials eventually read off the
list of charges against him you want to
know the charges yeah I do so it has two
burglary charges listed a theft charge
on this shift that's on my old case uh
three charges of burglary of a vehicle
in the human trespass yeah what what why
is that floating up now Adams then asks
whether someone can pick up the vehicle
for him is this your vehicle it's my
rental yeah your rental okay
so can my parents at least come and get
it sheriff's deputies then call Adams's
mom about the vehicle hey this is Deputy
Giddings how you doing
good I well I know I'm sorry we're just
calling to let you know that the car the
pennant has if you guys are willing to
come pick it up it's over here about
milepost six on 491. after Adams is
taken to the county jail his father San
Juan County Commissioner Bruce Adams
arrives on the scene
any jokes
let me take the cars we don't have to
impound it
I don't want it impounded I know that's
why we're letting you take it Deputy
Wyatt Holyoke wrote in his report that
Bruce Adams was quote trying to use his
influence as a county commissioner to
intimidate him he also stated that Bruce
Adams swore him multiple times demanding
to see his son's warrant okay where's
Kenneth he's in jail they took him Roy
took him to jail they took him to jail
and I stayed here with the car why Fair
Lawrence who do I call to find out find
out the warrant you're a police officer
tell me who I call to find out why he's
in jail Deputy Holyoke then calls his
boss asking whether he's allowed to show
Adams his son's warrant hey boss
hey so I got Bruce Adams here
um Braden took
Kenneth to jail on a warrant can I show
Bruce the warrant what's the protocol
there yeah it's pretty mad
eventually the deputy is given the okay
to show Adams the warrant I got to be
careful with this stuff Bruce you
understand that
okay that's the warrant okay so it says
warrant status active offense burglary
burglary theft criminal mischief
burglary of a vehicle burglary vehicle
burglary you've been to court over that
Criminal Trespass normal 7th District
Court Monticello Bruce we don't have
anything to do with that all we know is
that the is that the warrant issues it
current did the court issues a warrant
that's all we know Adams pushes back
saying his son has already been to court
and accepted a plea of abeyance
Billy been to court and been charged he
has a plea and the babies don't know
that I I don't know Bruce I have no idea
who knows the courts you can the courts
no I can't get to the court until Monday
right because of a son of a billion
thoughts arrest it's you saw the warrant
right there I showed you in the corner
I've been charged with that and he has a
plea in advance on all of it Adams then
asked the deputy to release his son from
jail what do you want me to do I want
you to turn him loose I can't turn him
loose Bruce who can nobody can he's been
arrested for a warrant the corpse can
and the warrants false huh the words not
false orange after that he threatens to
pursue legal action against the county
you want me to sue the son of a
County Sheriff because he arrested my
kid on a fault score the orange right
there Kenneth Adams was released from
jail days after his arrest and the
warrant was later withdrawn long crime
Network reached out to Bruce Adams for a
comment on this story but have not yet
heard back reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie